this November 100% of the presidential
candidates will be politicians is this
really a choice let's consider the facts
regardless of party affiliation
politicians are more interested in
stealing babies than almost anything
else
hedgehogs meanwhile can fit comfortably
into your cupped outstretched hands
coincidence I don't think so the best
possible time that a politician can have
is when he or she is filibustering which
is a fancy word for wasting time
hedgehogs on the other hand put on tiny
little hats and go for walks which is
not a waste of time at all in cold
weather hedgehogs find a warm blanket to
curl up in and they comfort themselves
by imagining even smaller hedgehogs
curled up in even smaller warm blankets
whereas politicians maliciously take out
their frustration at the poor climbeth
on innocent bystanders that's right
kittens hedgehogs are particularly fond
of cupcakes politicians will eat
anything that is handed to them if they
think it will ingratiate them with the
public when politicians are in need of
comfort they hold each other's hands
pathetic
whereas a hedgehog can sit in your hands
not pathetic at all when faced with
adversity politicians make pouty stink
faces and yell at people
a hedgehog knows no adversity
when a hedgehog looks into your eyes you
can see into the warm depths of her
gentle gentle soul to avoid a similar
and far more disappointing soul gazing
politicians are never seen without their
sunglasses never ever politicians get in
tanks hedgehogs get in pumpkins
politicians relax by pretending to be
fighter jet pilots hedgehogs relax by
pretending to be soft-boiled eggs the
Hedgehog is quite sensibly wary of the
rabbit politicians on the other hand are
incapable of showing restraint around
the rabbit regardless of the danger to
themselves their loved ones or indeed
the United States of America when a
hedgehog tells a story you listen to
that story politicians think that a good
story is the one about the time they
went to a mattress Factory
politicians always look like they're
about to throw some sort of a tantrum
hedgehogs look like hairbrushes
politicians allow their dogs to decide
where they're going and by extension
where the entire country is going
hedgehogs consider dogs their peers but
not their betters hedgehogs take baths
in the sink and when they're not bathing
hedgehogs like to stay dry when
politicians aren't bathing they like to
make it rain and finally here is a
hedgehog in a slipper that is also a
hedgehog
are you still seriously thinking about
voting for a politician in November and
vote Hedgehog this message was approved
by everyone
you
[Music]